it would be difficult to check out
everything leaving Netflix in August so
we have a list of the best of the best
films you have to watch before they
disappear between now and the end of
August sign into your Netflix account
and load up these movies you won't want
to miss Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas
Terry Gilliam's psychedelic satirical
black comedy based on Hunter s
Thompson's book of the same name is a
flick you either love with every fiber
of your being don't really understand or
haven't seen it all or maybe you just
don't like it because that's fair - the
film divided critics upon its release in
May 1998 largely for its pendulous
nature and bizarreness that can make
your head spin but in the two decades
since fear and loathing has picked up a
swarm of fans who will go to bat for it
set in 1971 Fear and Loathing in Las
Vegas centers on journalists Raoul Duke
and his lawyer dr. gonzo as they take a
road trip from the sunny skies of Los
Angeles to the Sinfield deserts of Las
Vegas what begins as an effort to
document a race devolves into an
exploration of an otherworldly dystopia
that gets more and more haunting the
further Duke and gonzo venture in there
was evidence in this room of excessive
consumption of almost every type of drug
known to civilized man since 1544 ad
some think fear and loathing as
Gilliam's worst film by a mile
while others have called it quote a
stylish and faithful adaptation of a
lasting classic of American literature
hurry and find out which side of the
argument you fall on or revisit an old
favorite before Fear and Loathing in Las
Vegas departs from Netflix on August 1st
want to indulge in some silly scares as
summer winds down before August first
load up Netflix and watch the first four
installments in the over-the-top horror
franchise final destination each entry
in the saga centers on a group of young
adults who fight for their lives after a
friend of theirs is suddenly struck with
a vision and warns they will all die in
a freak accident all seems okay when the
group isn't involved in the accident
their friend foretold but the hand of
fate soon swoops down and plucks them
off one by one killing them via
elaborate Rube Goldberg style
coincidences there's no avoiding death
or their final destination the grave
though none of the final destination
movies have been critical hits they've
performed fairly well at the box office
and have amassed something of a cult
following
they're campy and a name and the perfect
movies to mindlessly watch after a long
summer day spent lounging in the Sun
writer director Edgar Wright and writer
actor Simon Pegg started the three
flavours Cornetto trilogy with 2004 as
zombie romp Shaun of the Dead then built
it out with 2007 s Hot Fuzz the comedy
stars Pegg is London police constable
Nicholas angel and his Shaun of the Dead
co-star Nick Frost as angels overeager
partner danny butterman i distracted him
in the cuddly monkey and then I said
playtime's over I hit with the piece of
it after angel realizes that his
flawless track record of catching
baddies has made his London superiors
angry he's transferred to the quiet town
of Sandford and partnered up with the
action movie aficionado butterman angel
reluctantly settles into the calmness of
the countryside town and gets used to
having the oafish butterman at his side
but things take a dark turn when a
string of accidents unleashes horror and
chaos onto Sandford the two cops buddy
up to discover the culprit and the true
meaning behind the crimes Hot Fuzz
regarded as everything in action comedy
should be leaves Netflix on August 1st
in case you didn't already know nobody
tells me nothing
[ __ ] directed in co-written by Luke
Poisson the Fifth Element takes place in
the 23rd century when earth is on the
brink of collapse hundreds of years
after race of aliens collected four
elemental stones from Egypt in 1914 it's
up to korben Dallas and ex Special
Forces major and current flying taxicab
driver and Lilu in orange haired
humanoid who crashes into said taxicab
to combine the four elemental stones
with the fifth element to prevent a
massive ball of flaming death from
hurtling into the planet Dallas and Lilu
meet a host of colorful characters along
the way which makes their already
unforgettable experience that much more
memorable be sure to catch the fifth
element before it leaves Netflix on
August first got your Twinkies got your
shotgun well get ready to roll because
the zombie apocalypse is about to be
over and you don't want to miss your
shot at killing some undead creatures
proven Fleischer's runaway hit horror
comedy zombie land follows a group of
four humans roaming the zombie
apocalypse making his way from his dorm
room in Texas to Ohio to see if his
parents are still alive geeky college
kid
Columbus meets three strangers who
become his makeshift family sisters
Wichita and Little Rock who have some
unique ways of dealing with chaos and
zombie-killing expert Tallahassee
there's humor and gore violence and a
kickin soundtrack and appearance from
Bill Murray as a fictionalized version
of himself and even some romance you
know something for everyone Zombieland
is set to jump off Netflix on the very
first day of August so hop to it then
look forward to catching the sequel
Zombieland double tap in theaters on
October 18th javier bardem has taken his
fair share of turns as baddies and films
like Skyfall and pirates of the
caribbean dead men tell no tales but no
villainous character Bardem has embodied
comes close to the psychopathic assassin
Anton Chigurh in No Country for Old Men
well there's an associate of yours where
I'm from friendo set up as a
cat-and-mouse game No Country for Old
Men begins with a discovery Llewellyn
Moss steps into the aftermath of a drug
deal gone wrong and finds two million
dollars in cash sitting in the back of a
truck it's an unexpected payday for Maus
but it changes his life forever when
sugar sets out to recover the money an
adaptation of Cormac McCarthy's novel of
the same name
No Country for Old Men is thrilling and
bleakly funny as it explores themes of
religion and fate against the arid
backdrop of the Lone Star State your
last chance to catch it on Netflix is
August 11th directed by Garth Jennings
in his feature debut The Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy brings the weird and
wonderful novels of the late Douglas
Adams to life in a way that no previous
adaptations could really manage excuse
me
The Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy
centers on Arthur Dent and English every
man who's having a particularly
troubling day he learns that his house
is scheduled for a bulldozing that his
friend Ford Prefect is actually an alien
journalist and that Earth will be
demolished to clear space in the solar
system for a hyperspace bypass Arthur's
only shot at surviving is to hitch a
ride on a passing spacecraft and thus he
embarks on a journey he never could have
imagined our unlikely hero discovers
that everything he thought he knew about
life has been wrong and everything he
needs to know rests in a book called The
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy also
starring Zooey Deschanel as a humanoid
named Trillian Hitchhiker's Guide has
been hailed as a delightful sci-fi treat
and it leaves Netflix on August 20th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]